auch die us demokratie wollen wir
sprechen mit dem bundesaußenminister
heiko maas schön dass sie da sind und
vielen dank haben sie gleich die erste
frage als sie diese bilder gestern
spätabends gesehen haben was ist ihnen
da als erstes durch den kopf gegangen
na ja also wir haben in den letzten vier
jahren einiges erlebt mit diesem
präsidenten
aber das ist dann noch mal etwas gewesen
dass schlichtweg meine vorstellungskraft
überschritten hat also wir waren im
flieger auf dem rückweg aus jordanien
haben dass das im flieger angeguckt im
live ticker oder im livestream
wenn man viele kollegen dabei die auch
mal als diplomaten in den usa tätig
gewesen sind und ich habe wirklich im
flugzeug seltenen situationen an lebt in
dem es so still gewesen ist bei uns das
tatsächlich alle die sprache verschlagen
hat hatten sie denn jetzt in der
zwischenzeit schon kontakt zu ihren
kollegen mike oder anderen mitgliedern
der us regierung
das hatten wir nicht aber wir sind
natürlich durch und über unsere
botschaft in washington gut informiert
da ist würde ich mal sagen große schock
starre ich glaube auch gar nicht dass
diejenigen die jetzt noch in der
regierung sind groß international
ausschwärmen um das zu erklären ich weiß
ehrlich gesagt nicht mehr was es da noch
zu erklären gibt ich habe einfach das
wichtigste ist dass der kongress die
richtige antwort gegeben hat und die
bestätigung der wahl von joe biden
nachdem die dann alle wieder raus waren
dann durchgezogen hat und jetzt klar ist
dass joe biden alle formalitäten erfüllt
hat am 20 januar präsident wird und
endlich auch der der mann im weißen haus
erklärt hat dass er jetzt eine
friedliche übergabe organisieren wird
das hat er jetzt endlich erklärt gestern
seine worte noch etwas anders es ist das
herzstück der us demokratie das
vergessen gestürmt worden ist welche
verantwortung trägt auch donald trump
selber für das was wir da jetzt gesehen
haben
ich würde sagen er trägt die volle
verantwortung dafür das ist nicht nur
zurückzuführen auf das was er gestern
gesagt hat heute diese rede die er
gestern gehalten hat sondern das hat
sich aufgebaut über vier jahre permanent
zu polarisieren menschen die
fehlgeleitet sind schlecht informiert
und polarisiert sind immer weiter auf
die bäume zu treiben und das was daraus
entstehen kann das hat man das gestern
gesehen und ich hoffe dass das eine
lehre ist für für alle nicht nur in den
vereinigten staaten was populismus
bewirken kann was polarisierung was hass
und hetze bewirken kann
solche bilder wollen wir nicht wer nicht
mehr sehen nicht nur in washington
sondern irgendwo auf der welt
wir hatten ja gar nicht so andere bilder
hier bei uns in berlin vor einigen
monaten als es auch einem ob gelungen
ist zumindest auf die stufen des
reichstags zu kommen
die bilder damals waren verheerend
glauben sie dass es hier eine vernetzung
gibt zwischen den leuten auch damals
haben wir gehört der mob in berlin hat
sich aufgemacht nachdem es hieß
angeblich ist donald trump in der
us-botschaft ähnliche pullover haben die
auf den treppen hier getragen wie
gestern was glauben sie wer sind diese
feinde der demokratie und wie vernetzt
sind sie miteinander die sind
miteinander vernetzt das konnte man
heute auch im netz sozusagen nachlesen
dass bei rechtsextremen und bereichs
bürgern parolen verbreitet wurden über
die sozialen netzwerke so nach dem motto
da können wir uns mal eine scheibe
abschneiden von dem was wir in
washington gesehen haben
das darf man nicht unterschätzen und
deshalb glaube ich ist das eine aufgabe
da geht es eigentlich nicht nur um die
regierung oder um die abgeordnete ist
eine aufgabe für alle demokratinnen und
demokraten solchen tendenzen permanent
entgegenzuwirken nicht immer nur wenn so
etwas passiert und groß aufzuscheinen
sondern das sind prozesse die sich
meistens über eine längere zeit an die
etwas zu tun haben dass hass und hetze
immer mehr die kommunikation in der
politik aber auch in unserer
gesellschaft bestimmt und dem muss man
mal ein ende setzen oder man muss dem
zumindest entgegenwirken sonst muss man
sich nicht wundern dass man solche
bilder sieht wie wir sie gestern aus
vorstellungen gesehen haben wenn sie
jetzt einmal zurückblicken die
vergangenen vier jahre was da alles
passiert ist und sozusagen dann gestern
nach dieser bilder die sprachlos gemacht
haben
mal ganz ehrlich wie froh sind sie dass
es am 20 januar dann endlich vorbei ist
ich bin sehr froh dass es vorbei ist
aber nicht nur das es dann donald trump
als präsident nicht mehr gibt sondern
dass leute in der administration in
washington das sagen haben
die wir aus denn das haben wir in den
letzten wochen gehört die die
vereinigten staaten wieder zurückführen
wollen als verantwortungsvoller player
auf der internationalen bühne die auf
kooperation setzen auf internationale
zusammenarbeit was ja auch in den zeiten
in denen wir leben bei all den
herausforderungen
ein beispiel die korona pandemie das
sind alles herausforderungen die kriegen
wir nur gemeinsam auf der welt gelöst
und ich glaube dass das prinzip von
donald trump america first nicht nur bei
den wahlen gescheitert ist sondern ist
überhaupt gescheitert
und ich bin sehr froh dass die neue
amerikanische regierung da völlig anders
auftreten wird völlig andere ziele hat
auf zusammenarbeit setzt und wir
brauchen die vereinigten staaten in der
welt um große konflikte und krisen zu
lösen um in den internationalen
organisationen wie im sicherheitsrat der
vereinten nation wieder in die lage zu
kommen auch kriege zu beenden politische
lösungen zu finden
in der beziehung waren die letzten vier
jahre ein totalausfall
bedauerlicherweise ich hoffe dass ich
das mit joe biden und seinem team jetzt
sehr schnell ändern wird das heißt sie
erwarten dass sich die beziehung
verbessern zu den vereinigten staaten
wieder na ja das ist ja nicht so schwer
die jetzt wieder zu verbessern wenn ich
mir angucke wie das in den letzten
monaten ja auch gewesen dass wir nochmal
erwähnen der so spontan verkündete abzug
amerikanischer soldaten aus deutschland
auch das ist ja jetzt gestoppt wurden in
washington also auch das sind alles
hinweise darauf dass man auch in
washington ein großes interesse hat an
besseren beziehungen zu europa aber auch
zu deutschland und darüber sind wir auch
nicht vor